you mutants are dangerous you're not
only anywhere
this place takes your greatest fear
place your live through it
Roberto
[Music]
Danny
brain we didn't get out of this together
this place is designed he puts his head
[Music]
[Music]
how so I the New Mutants rated pg-13 and
on July 23rd don't miss the New Mutants
panel at comic-con at home what's the
last thing you remember Danny you said
we had to route the reason you survived
it's because you're a very uncommon girl
[Music]
you're not not anymore
do you know a mutants or would anyone
like to shared their first time brain I
was 13 I thought it was a dream I just
lost control
Sam I started panicking people got hurt
Roberto my girlfriend
Liliana
I killed 18 men one by
[Music]
this isn't a hospital it's a cage
[Music]
it's important we find out your collar
so we can help you get better
I saw something I don't think she wanted
me to see
[Music]
I don't think we're here to cut better
this place takes your greatest fear
it makes relate to it until it kills you
[Music]
is there we can get out of this together
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you